ça va
réponse est importante et en tant que ce
soir c'est survenu aussi consulter la
soirée
voilà quoi diffusion d'un amour au
niveau de ceux qui ne savaient pas
ce sujet dans une famille pauvre
mon papa était gardienne
et ma maman était ménagé
mais avec la pauvreté
mon papa
larpent fut lui même et à l'alcool
il me dit ma part ni à l'école
et le salaire du 10 ans
à ce moment deux collèges et d'écoles la
scolarité contaminer les enfants à l'âge
de sept 7 ans
à l'âge de 10 ans je me suis dit que non
moi je te parle est heureuse à s'en
aller a de quoi comme un petit frère qui
saura de partir à l'école
j'ai décidé un jour de juin n'avait pas
aller dans la salle de classe
et a je suis arrivé
le maître a remarqué avec une tête plus
dans la place
est libre habile et je me suis approché
de lui et il m'a dit que l'homme m au
quotidien avec à ma place quand il ne
fait pas partie des élèves de madras nos
quotidiens et dino ceci le lien avec un
ami il ne me revient pas comme ça dans
la classe comme si c'était un marché
nous dit on bon si je vais apprendre à
lire et puis comme tous les autres
albums
il n'a pas voulu me contre 1 la prise
sur vous et il m'a battu battu battu
jusqu'à ce soir sous les taxes ou les
bases du jeu ne sort pas
il a tout fait j'ai dit je sors pas je
vais apprendre à dieu et comme tous les
autres enfants
mais quand il a tout fait il n'arrivait
pas à mes fins sortie il avait appel à
mon père
comme on parlerait vérité du fait de lui
ne voulait même pas me mettre à l'école
mais aussi la peu le voisin tout pour me
refaire une santé de la place par la
force c'est à ce moment que le directeur
de l'école il attendait de lui il est 10
heures à bourges il a demandé mais
qu'est ce qui se passe ici
cela le mènera dit que webkit est venu
d'entrer dans ma classe il dit qu'il
soit pas qu'il ne leur a interdit alors
qu'il n'a pas payé la semaine les frais
de scolarité j'appelais papa papa il a
couvert mais il refuse toujours de santi
jusqu'à drame sous les bancs
cela ne devait rentrer ici c'est comme
ça que mon papa n'a qu'à sortir aller
chercher et une ardoise et une craie
pour que je puisse aussi laissé avec les
enfants
de miss you
m'ont pas que moi j'ai commencé à la fin
de l'école à l'âge de 10 ans aussi peiné
donc on m'appellerait on m'appelle est
le papa de la classe
comme en vrai qu'on m'appelait le papa
de la place mais voit ça veut dire
renier ce que je voulais savoir ce que
je voulais c'est de savoir lire comme
eux c'est décemment écrit compte but
mais malheureusement
je suis arrivé à place de ciel
je devais faire une année un train pour
avoir incité
j'ai perdu mon papa très tôt
ensuite la maman donc j'avais tant de
difficultés pour continuer l'école
je n'avais pas les moyens de déplacement
pour aller à l'école donc 10 avait
demandé il fauteuil roulant comme ça
pour moi pour que je puisse aller à
l'école
mais gervais les pilotes parce que les
tunnels et un foutu je n'avais plus de
pneus brûlés dans moi je partage de code
avec
et bavay avec comme on appelle la junte
seulement y roule et la jambe messier
six et les bras jusqu'à un certain temps
un certain moment je ne pouvais je n'en
pouvais plus j'étais obligé parce qu'ils
font pas par abc henan
et il jette comme je ne pouvais pas
aller avec la roulette à skis ça me
plaisait les bras qui a obligé
d'appeler mon futur est
à 5 malgré
lui i mais il est amorti sur l'âme
celui qui m'attire dit appétit pour
aller à l'école
un millier en communiant avec la
métairie maire avait du mal à me ramène
à la raison que je viens que pour
comprendre le français lien que vous
savoir 10 avec un coup à droite une
connaissance dans la vie
mais quand j'ai entendu les parents y
avait plus personne pour me payer les
2000 frais de scolarité j'ai tout fait
et à sa forme était mal est donc mal
comme et du mas de roujou que maintenant
personne pouvait payer l'école de la
personne venir pied du col et tout ça ça
me faisait mal ça me faisait très très
très mal et entame
je me suis dit vraiment je veux vraiment
après avis des églises mais même à là ça
devient compliqué
je suis relevé un soir de l'école de
chézine pointe vieux clous et sur le mur
et jacques auger - sarkozy si c'est
comme ça je pour le plus aller à l'école
parce que quand je partais sur l'alcool
on se moquait déjà deux mois
et quand je n'arrivais pas à appuyer la
chorale dit tout la place se moque de
moi parce que je n'avais personne pour
pays donc c'est des idées mais sais-tu
marqué dans la vie
c'est que mon père
il ouvrirait à soir mes petits frères et
moins
et d'y toucher la tête de mes petits
frères et il est donné tous ces
pétitions
mais moi non après après avoir les béni
c'est la libre belgique
mon fils tu vas me pardonner de chagrin
de pays des petits frères parce que je
sais qu'ils jouent c'est tu deviendras
mais c'est eux je vais réussir les coups
qu'ils puissent venir un jour dvd à
l'aide parce que je sais que toi tu
pourras guinée très dans ta vie
geslin belli c'est au poids
maximal n'arrive pas à comprendre qu'on
prélève
pourquoi moi je peux pas un jour venu
s'occuper du maire mais le vrai
pourquoi tubéry mais les titres elle
débite udb nie pas
et j'ai décidé de ne plus aller à
l'école tu n'es plus et j'étais
découragé après avait la pression lundi
sec quand j'ai voulu et la pointe pour
accrocher mon sac je suis aller
maintenant pour aller pour faire comme
on appelle cherché à faire un travail et
ce travail se voit je cousais des soucis
les effets des soucis déjà on me donnait
ces mêmes français résidant à evra et
ses arrêts ça je prenne un pour reparler
vers donner à mes petits frères guichen
j'ai moi même arrivé à manger tard le
jure que je n'ai pas gagné je donne à
mes petits frères et puis moi j g j'ai
tort
il vous êtes vous avec eux dans la vie
si j'ai la volonté
et le courage tout ce que tu veux tu
l'auras dans moi j'ai décidé un jeu et
de faire aussi la musique
[Musique]
compte tout le monde je n'avais pas les
moyens pour aller en studio s'ils
n'avaient pas les moyens pour m'acheter
liens que il quitta quand j'étais obligé
de travailler tue de ne pas manger
souvent les oies pour décoloniser pour
pouvoir acheter elle ne serait pas de
musique
engagée une imputation des pays il dit à
irin ancien équitable une guitare
occasions et je me promenais j'ai joué
et je disais à mes amis que non un jour
tu veux deviner un grand artiste qui
devait chanter mais là les gens qui
venaient me dis il faut quitter dalsa il
faut chercher dans les métiers où les
deux dit que tu vas chanter que les
personnes valides des personnes bien
portants même en fait la musique ils
n'auraient qui n'en parlons pas des
personnes handicapées
mais aujourd'hui nous avons posé les
questions dans ses salles
moi j'aimerais que ceux qui
reconnaissent mon visage n'ont pas subi
les mêmes
aujourd'hui case amal amar amari tard
grâce
à main comme à mon handicap aujourd'hui
moi je vole un avion je parle en face
d'eux un concert en suisse je sais qu'on
sait où va la vie
tragique
et aujourd'hui je véhiculais elles n'ont
passé quand je marchais à quatre pattes
des amap et les contrées dont les ponts
effondrés
mais aujourd'hui même bbc de doter sa
femme m'appelle z mort
et j'avais une critique là aujourd'hui
je ne me promène que avec t elle évite à
old trafford
et quand je je m'arrête aller voir où je
peux faire rire les gens je peux fait
ainsi déjà et les gens même les armes
applaudi donc aujourd'hui je suis plus
un handicap mais on t'a dit pas ce que
je fais c'est que d'autonomie
chantier il s'en sort avec ma guitare et
puis je vais tenter avec la musique qui
mazères voyager sur le plan national et
international merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
garmisch
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]